foreign
this is Anna a laboratory research doll
she has done more for Humanity than many
human beings
Anna was used to develop the first
operation to cure blue babies
here is Michael Shermer
2412 East Lafayette Avenue Baltimore and
this is Peggy curlette
2635 Purnell Drive these children were
among the early cases to be cured by the
blue baby operation
they suffered from a birth defect of the
blood vessels near their heart which
prevented them from taking any exercise
even from walking more than a few steps
this procedure was such an important
advance in surgery that it created a
sensation throughout the world
over 800 children have now been helped
by this operation
today thanks to Anna and her kind this
treatment has become a standard
procedure
some 30 years ago dogs like Anna were
used to study diabetes and it was
through this research work that Dr
banding and Dr best discovered insulin
marvelous chemical that permits diabetic
people to live normal lives
here in Baltimore in the huffburger
laboratory of the Sinai Hospital is the
most modern development of the
artificial kidney this instrument has
already saved the lives of several
people
principle of the artificial kidney was
first conceived in 1913 by the late Dr
John J Abel of the Johns Hopkins school
of medicine
he used dogs exclusively in developing
his early model
here are some dogs that have had
artificial bladders constructed within
their bodies they are Lively and healthy
today two people have survived this
operation for the treatment of cancer of
the bladder until medical research with
dogs had shown that this operation was
possible no doctor would have been
justified in performing it on a living
person
the dogs that are used for medical
research in Baltimore institutions
receive the best of care
only those institutions approved by the
Commissioner of Health are allowed to
obtain dogs from the city pound for
research work
the dogs live in comfortable quarters
and often become the pets of the
laboratory workers many of them never
undergo any surgical operation
those that are operated upon receive
care comparable to that given to
patients these Laboratories have
received approximately 900 dogs in the
past eight months from the city pounds
over 8 000 dogs however were destroyed
uselessly at the city pound during the
same period of time
is ten percent of those dogs do to die
too great a price to pay for your health
and happiness
join with your doctor in this fight
help him to help you
your children and the future generations
to come